hey what's up my name is samuel leeds
and in this video i want to tell you why
logically you should never ever buy a
home okay you should never buy a home
and the reason is is because financially
and commercially it just doesn't make
sense to buy a home in my opinion listen
you can do what you want i'm just
telling you what i think from my
experience i have bought a lot of
properties okay i've bought myself and
my
clients that i've bought properties on
their behalf and um and and helped them
buy uh you're probably talking about 450
properties that i've either bought or
i've packaged and helped my clients buy
um so why do i send it by home there's a
difference between a home and a property
okay a home is where somewhere you live
this
this is my home where i'm sat right now
i'm in my home you might even hear in
the background my kids um playing in the
background this is my home i don't own
this
i didn't buy this if i bought this house
financially it would not be very smart
the only reason i'd buy this this home
to live in would be because i just want
to you know i might think i just really
like it but financially and commercially
it makes much more sense to buy
properties and then rent them out and
let someone else have it as a home okay
now you might think i'm splitting hairs
but there's a massive difference between
a property
that you own
and a home and the big problem that a
lot of property investors get when they
step into property investment is they
don't understand the difference between
a property and a home a house and a home
they don't know the difference so
because of that they make massive
mistakes let me explain some of those
mistakes i'm talking about number one
people when they buy properties they're
often going to buy to let go into real
estate they buy houses near where they
live
they buy a house near where they live
why do they do that because in their
minds they think oh it's got to be close
to home it hasn't it's a property
investment
if you're buying bitcoin or gold or
silver you buy it as an investment if
you're buying a
if you're buying shares in a business
you don't go i'm only going to buy
shares in a business if the business is
within half an hour of my home why not
because that would be ridiculous it's
the same when you're buying a property
investment and you're buying it to rent
out you need to systemize it have
management companies and procedures in
place and buy it because it makes sense
financially not because it's near your
home second thing that people do when
they get mixed up between houses and
homes is they buy properties that they
like so they look around the property
and they'll be like could i live here
myself oh i like the garden and they'll
invest their hard earned money
into a house into a home because to them
it's like oh this feels like a nice home
this it doesn't matter what matters is
is it gonna make you money it's a
property investment it's not a home you
should never ever buy a home and i said
samuel what about i have to live
somewhere where am i going to live
you're going to live
in a house which is your home that you
rent
and you're going to pay the rent with
the money that you make off of your
properties okay third reason is because
um when you buy a a home
the purpose of a home is it's somewhere
safe
it's somewhere secure it's somewhere
safe so what a lot of people do when
they buy a home is they pay off the
mortgage because they want to be debt
free
i understand that i understand that
you're paying off the mortgage because
you like this home you want to stay here
you want to be debt free and technically
is debt however when you buy a property
investment you shouldn't pay off the
mortgage
why because it's debt yeah it's still
debt but it's good debt because your
tenants are paying the interest on the
mortgage
so when you buy a property buy it in an
area that financially makes sense buy it
with formulas and not feelings buy it
and keep the debt and use the debt and
let the tenants pay the interest and you
keep the cash flow okay number four is
okay diy you know people say well i've
got a bit of diy to do in the house or
it needs a better diy work done to it
what does diy stand for it's something
that you do in your home and it stands
for do it yourself
when you're buying a property investment
diy shouldn't come into it okay and if
the property needs work it's not diy
work it is a business systemized work
that needs to happen it is a maintenance
put 10 of your rent that you get aside
for maintenance repairs and never do it
yourself okay last tip number five i
hope you enjoyed the video if you are
smash like is this
when you're buying a home to live in
you get attached you are emotional about
it when you're buying an investment
never get emotional never get
emotionally attached to any investment
property it is the worst thing that you
can do and if you in your mind you're
buying homes
you're going to be emotional about it
you're going to get emotionally attached
when you're buying property investments
it's always formulas and facts over
feelings and emotions so five tips
number one don't necessarily think you
have to buy close to home systemize it
number two don't buy a house that you
like buy a house that makes money number
three don't pay off the mortgage
because the mortgage is leverage is good
debt okay so you don't want to pay off
you want to use the money you've got to
buy more houses
number four don't do it yourself any
work any maintenance systemize
everything always replace yourself not
do it yourself and number five is do not
get emotionally attached to a property
investment that you are buying so the
conclusion is don't buy homes buy
properties and turn them into homes for
your tenants which ultimately is going
to give you an income if you enjoyed the
video hit the like button drop your
comments below in the comment box i'd
love to know what you think of course
subscribe you can subscribe up to the
channel over here if you want to watch
more videos check them out over here and
if you want to learn how to invest smart
and you want to find the best types of
property deals then i'm going to leave
the link in the description where you
can join me at the property investors
crash course where we're going to be
finding live deals and you can do the
same thing too